ukraine is calling on russia to allow
civilians to escape the southern port of
marijupo the local council says russian
forces who have surrounded the city have
reduced it to ashes with constant
bombing president voldemir silenski says
a hundred thousand civilians are trapped
without food water or medication
zielinski says russian forces seize a
humanitarian convoy attempting to bring
relief to mariupol's besieged residents
bombs keep falling on mariupo
the besieged city is under relentless
shelling by russian forces
satellite pictures show the extent of
the devastation
apartment buildings burnt out
a metal factory shelled
hundreds of thousands of people are
still stuck here under the falling bombs
at the moment there are around 100 000
people living in mariopol under inhumane
conditions under a complete siege
without food water and medicine under
constant shelling and bombardment
for several weeks we have been trying to
organize stable humanitarian corridors
for mario paul's residents and almost
all our attempts have been unfortunately
obstructed by shelling or deliberate
terror by russian occupiers
those who were able to flee mariupol say
conditions there are desperate
people of mario paul aren't being heard
they're in need of help
people don't have water they drink water
that's not even fit for industrial
purposes
there's no one you can ask for help
ukraine announced an agreement had been
found to evacuate residents from towns
and cities through nine humanitarian
corridors on wednesday
russia continues to pummel cities across
ukraine like here in the capital kiev
where drones attacked the scientific
institute
or here in kharkiv in the northeast of
the country where missiles fell
president volodymir zelensky is still
hopeful that talks with russia can bring
peace
he says ukraine is prepared to discuss
the status of crimea and the separatist
donbass region after a ceasefire
but any agreement would have to be
approved by the ukrainian people
we can speak now to our correspondent
fanifachar she is standing by for us in
western ukraine in the city of lev hi
funny we are hearing the news that an
agreement has been reached to evacuate
civilians trapped in ukrainian cities
via nine humanitarian corridors what
more can you tell us about that
well this is pretty good news if those
non-humanitarian corridors actually
operate and people can be evacuated
something of course as we have seen
during this war during the past weeks
either worked in a very limited way or
not at all and when it comes to the town
of mario paul unfortunately there's no
agreement there in terms of trying to
get people out and have a humanitarian
corridor established to get a
significant of number of people a
significant number of people out at
least 100 000 of people instead ukraine
said that in a nearby town they
basically set up transportation for
people who make it out of this far and
of course so many of them would like to
just make it here where we are right now
tulip which is basically the last town
on the way out from ukraine to poland
but millions and millions of people who
have that goal to finally leave remain
trapped in the residential areas remain
trapped in a situation where they
themselves do not know not just to how
to get out but even just how to get
basic information
how to make that attempt the desperate
attempt at this point especially mario
pool to exit ukraine yeah as you said
there are an estimated 100 000 civilians
remaining in mariupol it has been hit so
hard what conditions are they facing
it's really hard to put that in words at
this point just imagine for four weeks
now people either had limited access or
hardly any access actually to food some
of them are reported to drink
very unsafe water actually there is no
clean water no power and as i say no
access to communication you have to
imagine people are out on the street
they can't be buried and and people who
are in dire need of medical help to to
help survive
can't just make it to the next hospital
because they are bombed as the city
council pointed out yesterday from
ukraine they really uh painted a very
devastating picture calling mario paul a
place that's been reduced to ashes of a
dead land quote
i've never been to mario paul but just
from the sources we have on the ground
and if that information that we are
getting is just one part of the story i
don't even want to imagine what the full
scope of the devastation is in mario
paul
funny just a quick last question talks
to end the fighting have continued any
progress there
president zielenski said actually
early this morning that there is
progress that's being made step by step
at the same time he also said that
ukraine and russia remain
confrontational so in a way a mixed
message a message towards ukrainians who
are here who are showing resistance hang
in there there's going to be some
agreement at some point while on the
other hand those who can leave try to
leave from these besieged towns like
mario paul or kiev or
sumi and other places so if you ask me
personally and given the negotiations
that ukraine already had the delegations
of ukraine and russia i don't see any
immediate change at this point what
people are hoping here on the ground
with president zelansky reaching out to
various politicians but even to the pope
yesterday that at least a ceasefire or a
limited ceasefire can be reached
dw's funny father reporting there for us
from levitt thanks you thank you so much
we can get some more perspective on this
story now we'll with gosana mamedeva she
has ukraine's directorate for strategic
planning and european integration at the
ministry of digital transformation in
ukraine thank you for joining us here on
dw ukraine has made very clear it wants
to join the european union how likely do
you think that is
um first of all uh hello everyone and
and uh thank you for opportunity to
speak here uh actually the opportunity
is very real and it's necessary
um for the the for the peace and
security in europe and
it um
ukraine has been shown that it's deserve
it and it's fighting for strongly
fighting for the european union values
and uh for for the life actually and we
also see their really strong consensus
among european uh union member states
governments and also citizens uh and
really high support of ukraine accession
of the european union so this is
definitely that need to be we have this
agreement already on political level and
now we have to implement it but we have
to move really quickly
because of all the situation and
the both sides and the europe in general
are
greatly will greatly benefit on it miss
mamadiva you said that this would be
important for ukrainian peace and
security but we're not talking about a
nato membership here we're talking about
the european union so how would
that actually help ukraine right now
uh you see i i'm speaking it's not only
from the ukrainian perspective but uh
european union uh perspective because
it's it's clear uh time uh to take
leadership uh for the european union and
uh continue to actually to protect the
values that european union must uh
protect uh on the
and and why it was created for um we
already have as i said the great
consensus and support from the european
union members and and actually citizens
what is important we have unprecedented
level for example uh
almost uh 70 percent of germans support
uh ukraine accession to the european
union and
we also
proved that ukraine able to create to
integrate in the sphere
um even within the crisis and
now i'm speaking like referring to a
particular
example with the energy sector so you
can integrate it in the um
it's all system in in the european
energy system and also uh consumer
market uh
ukrainian consumer market is a great
potential for the european goods
ukrainian labor uh potential we already
uh have
one million ukrainians yes that
potentially contribute to the
development of the economy of european
european economy just to jump in there
ms mamadeva are you concerned that
ukraine's aspirations towards eu
membership
could perhaps threaten the progress in
any sort of peace talks with russia
definitely this is the choice of the
european of the ukrainians in it cannot
be changed by the russian will and it uh
ukraine will never be the sphere of the
influence of russia after what all that
happened and after all we bring and uh
uh like fighting for our freedom so
it's not the matter for the russia to
decide where ukraine will be its
ukrainian will and ukrainian the nation
of ukraine its support now 90 of
ukrainians wants to join uh
and uh like for the european choice of
ukraine
and i do want to ask you while we have
you we saw the german chancellor left
shoals today again rule out a nato
no-fly zone over ukraine even though
your president has asked specifically
for that so what is your reaction to
that
uh reaction of the the nato you mean the
position of the nato of the
this is actually negotiating and we see
that
that there is no
probably the
unity in member state because we say we
see how the different members uh
approach this
and understand actually the scale of the
conflict and this is not conflict
between ukraine and russia this is a
conflict between the european values and
democratic values and dictatorship so
this is uh negotiated and we still
continue to appeal to the world to the
european union to the nato
about what the danger uh we actually
opposed to and what we fight to so the
world have to wake up and understand if
what are the risks if not today but
sooner if ukraine's fall
all european security system fall
we have to leave it there gosanna
mamadieva director general of the
directorate for strategic planning and
european integration thank you very much
for joining us on dw
thank you
and andre osadchuk is a member of the
ukrainian parliament for the opposition
party hollows welcome to dw uh could you
first start by giving us your
impressions what are you hearing from
around the country
good morning thank you for having me
here
um i was able to listen to the previous
speaker on your air so
in fact everything is described
correctly so we have full scale war
so everything what your imagination may
paint about the
nightmare of war exist now in ukraine
the destruction of any kind of objects
school hospital museums theater
churches
uh dead bodies on the streets killing of
kids and babies
millions of people who are trying to
escape
some of them without any success like
not only mariupol almost the same
problem in chernige uh which is a big
city on the eastern ukraine uh
kharkevin's in very complex situation so
it is full-scale terrible war which was
organized by russian political regime
and which is executed by a russian
military and i would emphasize that i do
not think that it's correct to blame
just vadim
because thousands and thousands of
russian soldiers who are piloting jet
fighters and attacking helicopters who
are pressing bottoms on missiles launch
systems all of them are attacking
ukraine all of them are committing
crimes because it is crimes against
humanity it is war crimes that's reality
of ukraine for today but ukraine is
resisting
is extremely good so we know how to
fight we learn how to fight we burn
russians on the ground extremely well in
reality for for this almost month of the
war so russians get stuck
almost in all
points of the front line i want to
remind everyone that russians are
attacking us from all sides and our
border with russia is almost 2 000
kilometers so uh plus they use the bill
russian border too because we shall all
remember that bill russia also the part
of aggression against ukraine because
till today the russian land was used for
russian jet fighters and for russian
troops to enter ukraine so we are
fighting extremely good
in fact we stopped them the russian
losses are huge
uh till today they lose already more
than soviet union lost in war in
afghanistan which lasted 10 years
it's unfortunate to hear the license on
on both sides especially among civilians
and what you're describing there is
extensive war crimes just tell me your
father was also a member of parliament
and voted for independence in 1991. what
would he have said about what's
happening now
uh
i would say that uh my father did a
great job in uh
1991 with a very small group of
ukrainian democrats who was fighting for
ukrainian independence and they used
that unique chance which was in 1991 to
1991 to
create a new state because our
confrontation with russia it's very very
long story unfortunately not many people
understand all these details but it is
confrontation for the last 300 years
and we built our country we did our best
to develop and independent ukraine
finally but today it's continuation of
all the wars which ukrainian people had
with russia before because without
ukraine all the logic of russian empire
is collapsing because everything what
they promote into the external world
mostly about christian religion and so
on so forth everything is coming from
kiev because he was the cradle of all
the civilization so
russians are trying to fight for their
legend for their identity
and for us it's the issue of life and
death so
this fight this fight for um for for
independence has obviously backfired so
what's next and and tell me what would
your father have said
till the end we
we shall continue the job which previous
generations of ukrainians did ukrainians
were fighting for our land in 1920s in
1940s and 1950s and now in 2022 we
continue this fight so it's very very
long story and we are huge nation we are
still 40 million people in the center of
europe being
in the largest country of the europe and
definitely we are not going to step back
so neither me
nor my father if he would stay here with
me now or no other ukrainian politicians
will agree on any compromise with
putting on territorial uh integrity and
sovereignty of ukrainian lands in the
borders which were internationally
recognized in 1991 so we will fight till
the end and again we are doing this very
very well our big problem for today is
protecting of ukrainian sky
russians they are not able to move on
the ground they are not able to kill
ukrainian soldiers they are killing
civilians and they are taken us by
cruise missiles and jet fighters that's
why we need more help from the west to
protect our sky we are repeating this
for four weeks already that's the only
option how we can win this war let's see
what sort of response you get where when
world leaders come together on thursday
there are various summits being held and
that will certainly be one topic of
discussion andrea osadchuk member of the
ukrainian parliament thank you very much
you